Laverne Cox opens up about starring in a
new Rocky Horror Picture Show and
reveals her secret diet trip girl my
friend tons of pressure it's the
scariest thing I've ever in my life
um but it was really fun and it was
really gratifying and I got to make out
with like everybody curry is just so
funny and witty and he just has this leg
with that British cheeky humor that is
just everything the 32 year old actress
also gushed over a fashion favorite and
love jean shorts i love jean shorts
fashion please get act out when you feel
like the most confident yeah actually
and revealed how her doubt co-star
Katherine Heigl is helping them cut back
on sugar what I'd like to do is have
people eating sugar describe it to me so
I heck I thought can you taste it and
describe it to me please and I try to
live vicariously through so I am living
vicariously through Katie Heigl eating
for two right now my girl my friend had
to tell me all about it I'm like can you
please tell me everything about the tape
drive
texture how is it moist can you please
just give me everything